so offen aber läuft und jetzt
aktualisieren
etwas was ich eine anekdote und zwar
erinnere ich mich noch als ich damals
mal als ich damals 100 geknackt habe und
ich habe das damals über nacht und das
war richtig süß so nah vor mama hat das
ja nicht so wirklich so wirklich gepaart
mit gut so und dann könnt ihr plötzlich
mit einem kuchen an meinem bett als ich
100 gegner calista wie geburtstag oder
wird so genau so weit ich weiß dass das
werden wir auch wieder holen für dich
auf jeden fall hat er wirklich das war
richtig cool da ich dachte über kik cool
die feiern als auch das was ich mag was
ich gerne mache
feiern wir auch nie richtig richtig cool
aber tausendfache kastration ist sehr
stark wird sehr hart dafür gebunden ja
ich habe zeit gepumpt dafür leute ja
dann in diesem kleinen feinen spaß wie
du erstmal danke schön für 100k die
ganze unterstützung das war das zweite
große ziel was ich ihr video gesetzt hat
das habe ich jetzt auch erreicht und
jetzt auf ich mir ein an und dann geht
es darum sich neue ziele zu setzen und
einfach danke für unterstützung
freut euch da unterhalten